[Music]
I'd now like to introduce Mike Moffat
Mike is a well known economist and
writer who has a special interest in
innovation and its impacts on society he
currently serves at the Government of
Canada first-ever chief innovation
fellow where he's tasked by the
government to advise on the design and
implementation of Canada's innovation
agenda
he's also an assistant professor in the
business economics and public policy
group at the Ivies Business School and
Mike will respond to their own talk and
then the two of them will have a
conversation on these black chairs
followed by a Q&A
Mike thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
well first of all thank you for having
me here it's bit flattering and humbling
to be discussing economics with one of
my intellectual Heroes at an event
honoring one of my intellectual heroes
so so thank you and thank you for
walking us through this historical
context I think this is very important
that we often think of these issues as
being new but they're not wholly new I
mean we've been dealing with these since
ancient Greece as we saw and I think
that historical context is important for
policy makers as we try and figure out
how we should be responding to these
challenges so in my role as chief
innovation fellow there are two things
that keep me up at night there are two
things that I worry about the first is
what if our efforts are in vain that we
simply no matter what we try to do we
can't move the needle and innovation you
know what happens if we fail and we
could fail because nothing happens
or we could fail for a variety of other
reasons I'm reminded of a last year
Microsoft decided that it was going to
use machine learning to teach a bot how
to to chat like a teenage girl so they
decided to put this bot on Twitter the
next day the very next day The Telegraph
newspaper had the headline Microsoft
deletes teen girl AI after it became a
Hitler loving sex robot within 24 hours
so you know these things can sort of
blow up for a variety of reasons and I
think the first reason is don't put BOTS
on Twitter but the second thing that
keeps me up at night is what if our
efforts worked too well what if in facts
that Canada's innovation performance
takes off that we we make all the right
moves and Canada becomes very innovative
are we equipped as a country and as a
government to deal with those side
effects you know what happens if we
succeed and
we know that there are great deal of
benefits over potential benefits
innovation there are societal benefits
health benefits environmental benefits
but being an economist so I'm going to
focus on the economic benefits now as I
mentioned that you know there are a few
ways to generate economic growth the
first way is just through capital
accumulation you know more factories
more machines more equipment another way
is to simply increase the size of the
labor force and we we've done that over
the last 40 years as we got more and
more women into into the labor force and
larger numbers but basically throwing
more inputs into the economy or we could
figure out how to produce more with the
same seether more widgets or more
valuable widgets with the same level of
inputs in the crude language of growth
accounting we call this total factor
productivity or multi-factor
productivity really most of most of that
is essentially innovation and that's how
we get sustained long-term economic
growth is through that type of
innovation is figuring out how to
increase our total factor productivity
but that in so doing we create economic
rents or we create economic profits that
go beyond what's needed to cover
opportunity costs so you know Shawn
Peter talked about this quite a deal in
the quite a lot in the 1940s but these
ideas I should go back at least to Karl
Marx if not not sooner the idea is that
when we create innovations we create
those economic rents through some kind
of creation of economic power social and
Peter talked about the fact that you
have an innovation it takes a while for
your competitors to figure out how to
duplicate you duplicate that so that
gives you some deal of market power for
a while or that market power could come
from regulations that could come from
intellectual property laws that you know
we give you know this temporary market
power in a way to compensate innovators
for those innovations and recognize that
innovation has a
positive externality so we've heard
through the talk the distributional
effects that innovation can have on
employment through both enabling
technologies and sustaining technologies
but we also have to think about the this
issue of economic rents or the economic
gains from innovation because those are
going to have distributional effects as
well and often they're positive they're
not necessarily something we need to be
afraid of innovation can increase the
demand for labor as we've seen in
certain cases it can lower the price of
goods it can it can generate more tax
revenues for governments to spend on
social programs and training however
those rents can also flow
disproportionately to the wealthy
whether to be owners of capital very
high skilled labor
you know c-level executives
well-connected workers or so on as well
economic rents could also flow to
landowners which we've seen in some of
our more innovative Geographic clusters
across North America like in Silicon
Valley so any government grappling with
innovation must also worry about those
distributional impacts must also worry
about how to make that innovation
inclusive in an economic sense in a
social sense in a health sense but also
in an ability to contribute to
innovation systems that are are we
allowing everyone in our economy to be
innovative and to contribute to
innovative activities so that's where
I'm going to start our questions so
we're going to discuss for a few minutes
and then we'll open it up to the floor
and get some of your questions so I'm
basically is this my gonna be on that
okay so I'm basically going to get you
to do my job for me
how do it how do we deal with this
tension between the need to innovate you
know to generate total factor
productivity to generate economic growth
but also the need to be inclusive I
think that's a great question
think anybody knows do it fully well but
I think generally the gains from
innovation accrue in two different ways
one is that once we have a new widget
and start using that that's going to
change profits it's going to change
wages and that's what I was talking
about in terms of enabling and replacing
technology and I think there's a lot of
difficulty in dealing with these
technologies because many of them are of
this replacing nature
the second is which you have rightly
pointed out and I had admitted which is
that the people who create the
technologies are also getting some rents
and that's very important in most cases
quantitatively it's smaller than what it
does to the entire production process
and that's why I had not put as much
emphasis on it but you're absolutely
right and in the age of digital
technologies sometimes it's quite
intervened with with what's going on so
in some sense Google is both an
innovation company and it is producing
things such as add services
advertisement search products or other
information services so the two are not
easy to separate from each other and I
think in both cases there is no easy
formula to say we're going to make the
outcome of innovation the inclusive one
precisely because we're not anymore if
we ever were in the land of enabling
technologies but if that's the case we
need to start thinking about policy as
an additional lever in order to increase
the shared nature of the prosperity that
new technologies bring and for that
I think we need to have a longer
conversation I don't know how much of it
I want to start it now but let me sort
of
mention sort of three elements and some
of those perhaps we can come back later
the first one is we need to make sure
that these technologies are implemented
in the right way so that they improve
productivity so I advise I already
emphasize a lot of things flow from
productivity if we are not able to
implement the technologies because of
regulation because of absence of key
types of personnel that are necessary
because of monopolies that prevent them
then we're not going to get the
productivity benefits and we're going to
be hampered by so for example in the
robotics area you know us is squeezed in
two ways and the same is perhaps true of
Canada you know as opposed to other
technologies in the digital era like the
ones represented by Facebook from Google
Microsoft and some of the hardware
technologies u.s. is actually not a
producer of Robotics so they are fairly
behind in the most advanced applications
of robotics but on the other hand
they're also using them in various
different ways that are creating
pressure or labour so so it's just a
question of how do you best exploit them
and I think you need to be for countries
like Canada and the United States you
really need to be at the forefront of
these new technologies including
robotics the second is that the point I
made about complementary skills if we
have the complementary skills to new
technologies we both softened blow of
them because they're going to have less
of a displacing role and we can then
create wage growth for the workers that
have the complementary skills but here
and this is the one that requires a
bigger conversation is that we really
have no clue because I think we haven't
started having the in-form knowledge
based discussion of what are the skills
that new technologies require the United
States and many other countries are
putting a lot of emphasis on stem and
I'm totally
with that that's my favorite subject too
but is it really the numeracy skills
that are in shortage when we look at the
rollout of the AI and robotics if the
workers on the factory floor of Ford and
GM had better numeracy skills they would
not have lost their jobs it's not clear
when it comes to AI it's even more
complex because many of the things that
a AI is going to do is going to require
some sort of an human agent to input
information and to market and customize
those products so that might require not
just numeracy skills but a whole host of
communication skills social skills and
various other things it might also
require very much adaptability and
flexibility things that our schooling
system is not very good at instilling in
the students so we need to start
measuring what are the complementary
skills and start having a conversation
about how to change our labor market
institutions including training systems
in order to enable workers if it's
possible at all before they are to lose
too late to make the transition to
having but more importantly for our
students to start investing in the right
sorts of skills and acquire the
flexibility adaptability and the
complementary skills but even that is
not enough there is no guarantee that
you know displacing the replacing
technologies are going to lift all both
if the only you invest in complementary
skills you also need to start thinking
more seriously about how can we do a
better job in terms of our fiscal system
as social safety net in order to
distribute the gains from from new
technologies and I think here we have
some sort of encouraging size that
people are discussing things like
universal basic income and other ways of
redistributing resources and I don't
think Universal ways against this
assembly a great idea but I think having
the conversation about a better
redistribution system is very much
necessary having a better discussion
about social safety net a social safety
net that's not only ensures people and
their children against adverse labor
income shocks but also prepares them for
being reintegrated into the lane
market I think those are very important
things but the tendency of course in
many countries is in the opposite
direction and us already has a very weak
social safety net and is further cutting
it down and in many countries because of
budget deficits and fiscal squeeze those
social safety nets are in danger so I
think there needs to be a renewed
discussion of these issues in the in
light of the what the new technologies
will bring one of the things that that
innovation does is lower transactions
costs and we go back to sort of the
theory of the firm why do firms exist
it's to lower transactions I think part
of what we're seeing on sort of the gig
economy and the flexibility is you know
perhaps we don't need firms as much as
we used to because firms again we're a
mechanism of reducing transactions cost
first of all do you see that big true
and if so do we need to rethink things
like employment insurance and just and
you know job training based on
unemployment given that the this wall
between you know you're either employed
or unemployed might not be as distinct
as it was 30 or 40 years ago it's very
important and clearly you know what
people refer to as the gig economy for
instance as exemplified by uber is
changing the employment picture and but
it's making the issue of job security
and insurance and no less relevant so I
think we definitely need to have a
discussion on that some of it is again
regulatory in nature you know what
counts as the employment contract and
that's going to have some implications
but I think the more important part is
exactly like as you've pointed out
what's the role of firms and I think
here the puzzling thing is in some sense
that when you think of many of the
technologies based on the internet and
the information age they are
democratizing in nature
they open the platform to many people
and and and and and they make they make
transaction costs lower so therefore
many more transactions could be it could
be carried out but at the same time we
have never been as dominated by large
firms
we are at the moment so there is clearly
some amount of what economists call
increasing returns to scale that comes
from dominating information that is
making companies like Facebook Google
Microsoft much much more powerful than
any other company in the history of
humankind so I think one important issue
here is beyond the employment contract
we also may need to think about
regulations where does the comparative
advantage of many of these companies
come from it comes in part from their
technologies but also in large part from
their control of data so is it totally
fine for a company to collect data from
its users and use it in a proprietary
manner or is it the case that in the
same way that we shared many other
resources including rail lines some of
that data should be shared and I think
that's the discussion that that we
haven't started having yet well I see a
lot of people started jumping wanting to
ask questions so here's well here and
here so come on up if you want to ask a
question and if you don't because I've
got a lot let's go back to the skill
setting so this is I've got a six year
old and a two year old so this is
something I think about a lot of okay
what skills do they need because on the
one hand we do hear a lot of stems and
it's like okay well we want to have you
know kids be able to program these
robots and repair these robots and come
up with code but at the same time with
AI and machine learning you know I also
feel like we're getting to a point where
the these machines may in a sense become
self-healing or one minute one robot
will be able to build the next
generation of robots so first of all is
it parents how do we figure out what
skill sure we should be teaching our
kids but also as a school system as a
government how do we deal with that not
really knowing what the skills of the
future are going to going on and I think
I think that's that's the key question
and unfortunately I wish I had a much
better answer and part of the reason why
we don't have a better answer to this is
because people haven't been asking this
question so we don't even have the data
set or the sort of measurement and the
experiments in order to
answer it what we know is that during
this period in which inequality has been
increasing because of partly because of
new technologies and and and and and
transformation of the workplace we've
had soft skills as we measure in their
various datasets have actually become
more and more values so it's not true
that during this time period is the
numeracy skills that have become more
rewarded and soft skills have become
less important in fact if anything soft
skills appear to become to have become
more important and I think what that
reflects is what's going on in the
median in the middle of the wage
distribution so clearly if your children
are very very talented if they have the
chance to be an engineer for Google or
Facebook that's a great occupation and
they're probably going to do much better
than anything you can do with with just
sort of the usual sort of skills working
with robots or computers if you are very
at the very top of the hierarchy in
terms of these stem numeracy skills but
for many of the workers that are gonna
make up the bulk of the wage
distribution that disappearing middle
that I was showing you I think it's a
combination of skills but also it's the
ability to deal with change I think
what's going to characterize the future
is a much more fluid labor market if you
look at the career of a typical worker
in the US and you said you know who who
is the median worker in the US for
example who's just in terms of how long
he has been in a job and what you the
answer you would have got in 1980s is
that the typical worker has been in his
job for 20 or 20 plus years he's been
rising within the hierarchy of a large
company the two the products that the
company produces don't change perhaps
the management changes there are some
reorganizations every now and then but
it's a relatively safe environment that
safety was valued because that's what
people sort of nature is and we did not
give them tools for dealing with
adversity or changing their what they're
doing in a very very frequent manner so
therefore that safety was valued even
more but if those sorts of jobs are
going to be more and more scarce in the
future then it
more imperative that we provide the
students or the youth when they are
students with the sort of skills that
are going to enable them to be more
adaptable in their prime years
excellent so we've got so we'll go one
two three so keep them short
no no statements you know do you know
order questions Masquerade two
statements we have robots in the room
they will take you away if you go too
long and then my name is a few ponies
you who will work for the federal
government something I like to ask is
thank you advantage of your expertise in
economics when I'm trying to figure out
is to what extent modeling and trying to
predict the effect intelligence and
robotics to what extent would you say
the the there's reliable models as
somebody working in policy to what
extent should I rely on ask you very
frank on your predictions and your
public's predictions to various public
policy
my name is Bryson mass I'm a freelance
journalist and I basically would love to
hear an expansion on why the universal
basic income or your the reason why you
don't think it's not necessarily the
best idea okay you buddy I
I completely understand right now
interested for example the Danish tech
security model could be very interesting
in order to increase social security in
order to have a good living wage but
this is still thinking about social
inclusion of workers like the only base
true wage labor in a society where this
wage labour is becoming well bit
problematic is just just your curve on
the grader in college graduates yes it
is increasing but same thing yourself
one of the main factor of inequality
right now is what we call skill-biased
technological change so even with
university education you can end up with
acquiring skills that are just
completely not relevant anymore
once you're right on the labor market
and you end up with the losers even if
you have career in college education so
for me
maybe not universal basic income but
having this discussion of how to delink
income with wage for that which will
labour productivity I think is something
absolutely important that it needs to be
the other question thank you for saying
that nature of the firm's is not only
about reducing transaction cost for me
this is pure nonsense the importance of
business power in place especially in
the world you mentioned in terms of
power over control of data yes
absolutely
but when you look at the regulatory
capture right now between politics and
economics so basically corporate
interests being able to do I'm here I'm
here in the robots I'm kind of scared in
terms of the shape of the corporate
landscape emerging out of this new world
of technology robotics and this
concentrate concentration of
centralization of information excellent
thank you thank you those are great
questions let me I think the last two
are sort of
very connected so let me take those two
last and then just briefly respond to
the first question I think you know we
don't have great models that you can
definitely trust in fact that's what I
was trying to emphasize that if you took
a model of the labor market that you
know seemed to do a really relatively
well for the 1970s and the 1980s and
applied to the data for the 2000s it
doesn't work very well because the
nature of technologies is changing and
our ability to know what the future
holds is of course hampered by two
things we don't know what future
technologies are going to be and we
don't know what their implications are
going to be so for example you know very
well publicized paper by two oxford
academics Frey and Osbourne sort of
created these scores or probabilities or
which jobs are going to get automated
well that's entirely based on projecting
what we know in terms of technology
today well into the future which is very
very fraught and I think you're not
going to you're not gonna want to attach
much confidence on such numbers but even
if those numbers were true what their
implications for labor wages employment
that's where you need the economic
modeling and and there are a lot of
uncertainties but the best we can do is
really look at what the sort of research
that I was quickly summarizing look at
types of technologies that are
representative as we representative as
we can be of what the future holds such
as robots or AI and look at what has
happened when they have been rolled out
and again that's no there's no guarantee
that the future will play out exactly
like that and and and my discussion of
the British Industrial Revolution was
exactly that that the early implications
of the power looms were very different
than their later implications but there
is no substitute for really looking at
the data and trying to understand what
the labor market is going to do in
response to these new technological
opportunities in terms of universal
basic income I think that's a very
important question as a debate well
worth having
and and I'm not going to say that
universal basic income is definitely a
bad idea but what I suspect is that
there are two reasons why it is not the
best we can do and I think both of those
are important and need to be debated and
talked through more more seriously and
they relate to the second question that
was asked the first one is that I think
economists sometimes think in a
simplifying way that all we care about
is is income and and and and and work is
something we do just to get income it
might even eat into leisure time and as
there's some degree to that that's
that's true but also for a vast majority
of people they define themselves through
their work so I think it is a very
dystopian world in which large numbers
of people stay at home and play video
games and just live on a universal basic
income I think it is a very dangerous
feature in the same way that it is very
difficult to get a country in which
nobody pays taxes say like in Saudi
Arabia but then you actually expect them
to be citizens that's not gonna work
very well it's gonna be also very
difficult where people don't do anything
productive when you expect them to do
citizens so that's why I think the more
optimistic scenario is one in which we
find a way of leveraging policy and
technology together to create jobs and I
think that goes to the question that the
second the last question and that's
better than just providing a handout in
the form of a universal basic income and
then the second thing is that but I
don't doubt that we do need to
redistribute but when we need to
distribute I think universal basic
income is not an efficient way of doing
that because why should we be giving
universal basic income to Bill Gates and
Sergey Brin I think the taxes are
expensive it's difficult to raise taxes
it's difficult to collect taxes we
should direct the resources to the
people who are in most need which is the
the driving force of the classic social
you know social safety net which is that
you find a way of in a way to channel
the resources to the people who are most
in need without creating this incentive
and I don't see any reason for changing
that big trade off and moving to a
universal basic income we just need to
find the right way to redistribute and
make the redistribution generous enough
that people can bounce back from
adversity consequences that they will
often suffer fact well we'll take three
more questions one two three and again
we'll keep them
I think tight hi my name is Teresa troll
I work at the Canadian Museum of History
the program interpreter and hostess I'd
just like to point out or to observe
that the old and the new will always
coexist so there will be people engaged
in the nuit technologies and there will
be those who will maintain the older
knowledge base and both are valuable
there's nothing wrong with having
redundant technologies or maintaining
the knowledge of co-working ironed by
hand so if you like to comment on those
issues okay - hi my name is Siddhartha
Kumar my question is how does government
and innovation work are they friends are
they I'd like to think so but I'm not an
unbiased observer because innovation
while I you know like this that show
that the government is encouraging but
then you know always just laying about
you know changing the rules you know
automated car and all that so where does
government is government innovative
enough to you know face those challenges
will be equipped to deal with them great
question if you got to be dictator for a
day
what is one change you would make in the
US
[Laughter]
a better you than me okay well let me
start with the old and the new yes
absolutely and I think that is very
important to note and that's the reason
why I don't believe that robots are
going to AI is going to take away all of
the jobs many many things that humans do
and will continue to do and new ones
that they will invent will be outside
the capabilities of robots and and I
don't I think some of it is old you know
by creating a piece of art or counseling
things that are very much human base
that are that have been going for for
centuries are going to continue and in
fact when I talked about the
productivity effect how are you you know
when you increase the reduce the cost of
autos you're going to want to consume
more of everything well that actually
acts off in a non neutral way and that's
what sometimes it's called in an
economics the ball mills disease but
it's actually not a disease it's
actually quite a good thing and what
most disease refers to the fact that
productivity is not going to improve the
same every sector so if health care does
not have as much productivity
improvements or if education does not
have as much productivity improvements
as manufacturing then the prices of
those things is going to increase and
those increase prices are going to
attract more labor in order to increase
quantities in those sectors so therefore
Momo's disease even though the name says
disease is actually quite a good thing
because it points out how we can create
employment in relatively high
value-added sectors in an age when there
are improvements in the manufacturing
sector about government and innovation I
think that's a great question and the
picture is a very complex one if you
look at many of the important
technologies of our current age
foundational work has been done in
conjunction sometimes with direct
support some live in direct enrollment
of the Gov
the healthcare is the most obvious
example where pretty much no important
innovation has been without funding of
the government but the same is true for
the Internet the same is true for
self-driving cars the same is true for
sensors so government's role is
absolutely central however it is also
important to bear in mind that
throughout most of humanity the state's
power has had a much more complex
relationship with innovation many
despots many dictators and some elected
governments have feared technology and
have not always been welcoming to it and
I think part of the reason why it's so
central so critical for us to have an
informed debate about AI and robotics is
because the the the worst case scenario
is not in my opinion that you know
robots are gonna come and destroy the
jobs but the worst case then I little
risk or destroy work for everybody the
worst case scenario is that we are going
to destroy the robots and if you keep on
doing nothing exactly the same cycle as
we've had for globalization could happen
for robots which is that for
globalization for a long time we did not
make an effort to make the games shared
and that led to a huge populist
right-wing populists often but sometimes
left-wing populist arise that for
example brought brexit and worse brought
trump to power in the United States and
now many of those globalization sort of
treaties are being torn apart and there
are very worrying policy changes in
every dimension from climate to
international cooperation well if we do
the same for robots that we don't really
deal with their consequences I think the
chances that there could be a backlash
against technology is a real one and
we've experienced that throughout
history including during the Industrial
Revolution many times so I think that's
that's that's that's something that
have to really take into account I think
if I were a dictator for one day I would
want to resign immediately because I
think the only way we can deal with the
problems that we have here is as a
society not with the dictatorial power
or one single individual I think it's
very difficult to make sort of the
democratic system work but I think how
that gives us hope there aren't great
comment to end your discussion on good
afternoon my name is barb stylist and
I'm the current chair of the board of
the Canadian stitute for Advanced
Research and I did follow the very big
shoes of David dodge in whom this
lecture that we all participated in
today's is named so I do hope that all
of you enjoyed it as much as I did I
think that we've all learned a lot thank
you to to Mike for his leading us
through his views and for leading us in
the in the quite vibrant Q&A I think for
those of you who don't know see far we
bring together about 400 of the world's
best researchers Darren and his girona
and his colleagues and they are from all
over the world doing equally fascinating
work and we bring them into networks
that allow them to share their insights
and to build more and more insights
together so this very secret sauce is
creating world's world knowledge that I
think will better mankind and you had a
little bit of an insight today and I
think as the individual researchers come
together they learn from one another and
I think that's the sort of catalytic
nature of what we do at CFR that will
allow us to continue to contribute to
solving the world's greatest problems if
you'd like to know more about CFR and
stay in touch and to find out what our
fellows are doing I think many of you
will see our reach magazine on your
chairs I encourage you to read it it
tells you how to stay in contact with us
we are delighted to be here in Ottawa we
do events around the world mainly in
Canada though and mainly in the main
centres but it's a great pleasure to
have such an audience here today I think
it's a very diverse audience from our
nation's capital we're all happy to be
here on our country's one hundred and
fiftieth so thank you for joining us at
CFR's lecture in honor of David dodge
and I wish you the best for the rest of
the day Thanks
[Applause]